quand on m'a donné le thème contre la
montre moi j'ai immédiatement pensé à un
moment
j'avais une dizaine d'années douzaine
peu près et
je suis chez mes grands parents j'aurais
la télé le tour de france en particulier
mois contre la montre égale tour de
france et je vois la dernière étape sur
les champs elysées on est dans les
années 80 est peut-être en souvenez mais
laurent fignon perd le tour de france
pour 8 secondes pendant un contre la
montre je suis sidéré dans la télévision
et surtout je me dis
à un moment donné il sait qu'il a perdu
tour de france à un moment donné on lui
dit c'est fini tu as perdu tu as perdu
le contre-la-montre c'est greg lemon qui
va gagner le tour de france
mais il reste encore quelques centaines
de mètres sur les champs elysées et là
j'ai très clairement dans la tête
laurent fignon
qui accélère qui accélère qui accélère
et qui finit en trombe mais il sait
qu'il a perdu et pourtant il accélère et
à l'époque je suis dans un océan de
sidération je dis mais qu'est ce qui se
passe dans la tête
d'un champion qui sait qu'il a perdu un
contre la montre et qui pour autant
continuer à se battre contre la montre
parce que s'il a perdu le contre la
montre bien qu'il a gagné donc ça à
l'adolescence j'ai compris un truc on
peut gagner un contre la montre en
revanche ce que j'apprends ce jour là
aussi c'est qu'on ne peut pas gagner
contre la montre parce qu'évidemment
aussi courageux soit il aussi rapide
aussi puissant soit-il il n'arrive pas à
remonter le temps et quand ils arrivent
ils s'écrasent par terre et il a perdu
contre la montre et il a perdu contre la
montre
on ne peut pas gagner contre la montre
et ça j'en étais persuadé très longtemps
peu près une dizaine d'années
dix ans plus tard on est dans les années
90 plutôt vers la fin des années 90
et
je suis moi même à ce moment là
pratiquement physiquement dans un
sablier
rassurez vous je ne suis pas vraiment
dans un sablier je n'ai pas perdu un
pari je donne un sablier parce que comme
pas mal d'entre vous je passe un
concours l'agrégation d'histoire tout
est chronométré
il faut faire tant de fiches par jour
dans la douche il ya des fiches accroché
peut-être connu ça oui apparemment
il ya une dead line très précise au mois
d'avril il y aura quatre épreuves de 7
heures chacune lever les stylos
l'épreuve est terminée j'ai l'impression
physiquement d'être dans un sablier
moi-même et physiquement de passer de la
partie haute vers la partie basse est
tenté de résister pour ne pas tomber
dans la partie basse
bref je suis dans cette situation là
lorsqu'après avoir passé une journée de
travail assidu on est au mois d'août le
concours est dans longtemps mais j'ai
commencé tôt parce qu'il faut bien lutté
contre la montre même si je sais depuis
quelques années que je ne gagnerai pas
contre la montre pour vous avez compris
donc passé une journée à réviser en
pleine chaleur parce que c'est le mois
d'août c'est important pour la suite de
l'histoire et j'ai laissé les volets
ouverts toute la journée et le soir venu
je vais dîner je laisse les volets
ouverts
et un peu plus tard je reviens pour
travailler encore un petit peu dans ma
chambre
et j'entre
dans ma chambre et là je vois
entrer quelqu'un par le par la fenêtre
au
début je ne comprends rien je dis tiens
mais que fait cette personne qui passe
dans la par la fenêtre et puis une
deuxième
et puis le troisième et puis une
quatrième personne entre dans cette dans
cette chambre dans cette maison cette
maison je suis seul
et là quelqu'un de saute dessus
me met la main sur la bouche
sort une arme à feu
et là mais sur ma nuque en me criant
dessus
argent argent j'ai plutôt compris ce
qu'il voulait me dire ils voulaient de
l'argent
un autre sur un couteau
me le dépose
à ces délicatement sur le dessus de
l'oreille il me mena sera par la suite à
nombreuses reprises de me couper
l'oreille si je lui donne pas argent
argent vous aviez compris
et je me retrouve tout à coup dans une
situation
comme on l'a qualifié
atypique
ubuesque
inconfortable
terrifiantes au début en tout cas je
suis dans l'action
je prépare l'agrégation j'ai un objectif
dans quelques mois il n'est pas question
que ces quatre types
plus costaud que moi chacun d'entre eux
viennent nuire à ce temps qui s'écoule
et qui pour moi marc marc un objectif
essentiel dans quelques semaines dans
quelques mois donc pendant un moment je
suis leurs alliés on va tous ensemble
chercher de l'argent
inutile de matières de ce couteau à
cette place on va y aller ensemble bon
je suis en fait à ce moment là chez ma
mère ne sait pas vraiment où il ya de
l'argent mais je cherche avec eux on
cherche on cherche on est ensemble on
est une équipe voyez on m'a dit on m'a
dit
conférence ted c'est un truc inspirant
alors c'est inspirant ça dans un moment
difficulté
le collectif l'emportent aux journaux
qu'on cherche on est là on dit mais où
est l'argent argent alors là on a trouvé
un terrain d'entente on a trouvé un mot
commun ils en ont peu d'autres démos je
la prendrai plus tard ils sont des
albanais du kosovo on n'a pas forcément
le même maillot mais on a la même
passion à l'époque l'argent
donc on cherche on cherche l'argent mais
malheureusement j'ai du mal à trouver de
l'argent tout au plus je trouve quelques
billets qui sont là bon jeu que je
redonne immédiatement
l'un d'eux boit pas mal de l'alcool du
bar familial ce qui m'inquiète
légèrement sur sa capacité à maintenir
ce couteau à bonne distance de mon
appareil auditif de mon oreille
mais bon la scène avance comme ça
j'apprendrai plus tard de la bouche de
la police que j'ai été victime d'un
saucissonnage ferme sympathique qui
depuis rend compliqué tout apéritif
et donc au bout d'un moment le couteau
est en pause est toujours ici il quelque
chose se débranche dans ma tête
une espèce de fatalité
de certitude que la mort arrive que la
mort est là qu il n'y aura plus
[Musique]
d'apéritif qu'il n'y aura plus
d'agrégation qu'il n'y aura plus de
fiches sous la douche qu'il n'y aura
plus de révisions qu'il aura plus de
sourires qu'il n'y aura plus d'amis
qu'il n'y aura plus rien et j'en ai
l'absolue certitude
ce qui fait que plus tard dans la nuit
quand enfin les quatre malfrats seront
repartis sans l'avoir tué vous en avez
la preuve
je découvrirai sur mon corps prenant une
douche ensuite des traces partout de
demain qui m'ont attrapé qui m'ont
attiré et c'est comme si mon corps avait
disparu à ce moment là pourquoi je vous
raconte tout ça vous raconte tout ça
parce que tout à l'heure je dis on ne
gagne pas contre la montre
laurent fignon n'a pas gagné contre la
montre il a éventuellement perdu un
contre la montre qu'un autre a gagné on
peut gagner un contre la montre mais à
ce moment là le temps avait disparu pour
moi véritablement à ce moment là je me
suis dit plus tard pas dans la
sidération tient tout à coup le temps a
disparu et d'une certaine manière j'ai
pu éprouver
quelque chose de l'ordre de gagner
contre la montre et je me suis dit en
préparant ce que j'allais vous dire bah
en fait
il ya que la mort où l'expérience de la
mort qui nous permet peut-être
d'avoir le sentiment de gagner contre la
montre vous avez remarqué ça se fait un
peu moins aujourd'hui mais
traditionnellement dans les familles
quand un mort moeurs ou contraints
vivants meurent on arrête l'horloge
comme si tout à coup on considérait que
enfin enfin on pouvait avoir gagné
contre la montre à ce moment là mais
durant l'existence la montre avant cela
montre avant cela montre avance les
suisses 10 il ne suffit pas de casser
une montre pour empêcher le temps de
fuir et bien à ce moment là je crois que
c'est possible alors tout à l'heure je
me suis amusé en vous disant il faut
être inspirant il faut raconter quelque
chose qui tout à coup résonnera en vous
et vous permettra en sortant dans la rue
face à ces bâtiments modernes ultra
moderne ultra ultra moderne de veut dire
ça y est j'ai appris quelques jeux sur
moi même je suis un homme différent face
à peu près comme ça que je me suis dit
que cette expérience que j'ai vécue que
je viens de vous raconter à les opérer
en moi que après la vie ne serait plus
jamais comme avant
dix ans plus tard
il m'arrivait une autre chose
alors que j'écrivais un livre sur john
kennedy
gt1 repris dans la vie mais avec quand
même toujours se souvenir de ce moment
important où tout avait failli basculer
et tout n'avait pas basculé j'avais un
rapport au temps qui était peut-être un
peu plus mesuré que par le passé et
arrive un deuxième moment une deuxième
expérience de la mort je ne sais pas en
tout cas d'une possibilité de la mort
on est dix ans plus tard quasiment vingt
ans plus tard par dont quasiment jour
pour jour et on me diagnostique un
cancer
comme beaucoup de chance rien
d'extraordinaire je suis en train
d'écrire un livre sur john kennedy
j'écrivais avant déjà et j'étais fasciné
par john kennedy qui
malgré toutes les blessures de son corps
tous les malheurs de son corps ne se
plaignait jamais
savait qu'il avait des maladies très
graves maladies du dos la maladie
d'addison il malade et des glandes
surrénales c'était quelqu'un qui
probablement n'avait pas beaucoup
d'espérance de vie lyon lui donner 50
ans maximum mais depuis l'adolescence il
était toujours à l'hôpital trois fois
l'extrême onction bon et il ne se
plaignait jamais et mois avant de tomber
malade j'étais tout à fait impressionné
par cela je me disais mais quel talent
quelle force de caractère
extraordinaire et puis en cours
d'écriture on me diagnostic ma maladie
et je me retrouve à l'hôpital
tout à coup à nouveau le temps change
complètement de structure le temps
devient celui finalement du
goutte-à-goutte d'une chimiothérapie de
semaine entre traitement d'une hypothèse
de fin de traitement le temps a changé
vraiment de nature à ce moment là mais
je continue à écrire notamment à
l'hôpital et je me rends compte que moi
malgré mon cancer qui se soigne très
bien je me plains tout le temps
tout le temps oh la la c'est un jeu de
vomi oh là là ça me rate oh là là j'y
arriverai jamais oh là là où sont passés
mes cheveux
on ne retrouve pas tout vous sera passé
mes cheveux et je me dis mais en fait
kennedy qui ne se plaint jamais c'est
pas extraordinaire s'est pas vu c'est
pas malheureux en fait c'est louche
c'est louche et je commence à comprendre
qu' il y à une injonction du père et que
chez les clients ne se plaint pas parce
que si on se plaint c'est qu'on ne fait
pas partie de la famille donc je
reconstruis complètement une chose que
j'avais construite en un temps normal et
je suis rendu compte à ce moment là et
c'est l'un des premiers enseignements de
ce que je vous ai raconté que notre
perception du vivant
change je crois à mesure que
l'expérience s'invite dans notre chair
et cette expérience de la chair à la
fois avec mes kosovar et les et le
saucisson est à la fois avec avec le
cancer vingt ans plus tard m'ont dit des
choses je crois très profonde sur le
rapport que je pouvait entretenir aux
autres et en particulier au temps alors
si on était dans une conférence ted
c'est le cas des jeux devrait en sortir
parce que le temps file en vous disant
je suis sorti de tout cela de ces deux
expériences de la mort possible avec une
leçon que j'aimerais que vous gardiez
chevillée au corps en sortant de cette
salle je devrais en avoir tiré des
conséquences très profonde sur le sens
de l'existence sur l'incapacité
l'inutilité de tenter de retenir le
temps qui fuit quoi qu'il arrive
mais en fait pas du tout
clément quand il m'a présenté il a dit
que je faisais des chroniques sur france
info que je faisais des vidéos sur brut
que je présentais une émission sur
france 5 tout ça je le fais en
permanence avec en tête le temps qui
passe la seconde la vanité du temps
vanité de toutes les vanités tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps
franchement de tout cela il ne restera
rien
même là j'entends de vous parler et le
temps passe et le temps file et le temps
est en train d'arriver au terme de cette
petite conférence
après l'expérience que je vous ai donné
tout à l'heure je pourrais dire je me
fiche du temps je suis au delà de ça
j'aurais même pu décider de ne pas venir
parce que pourquoi tenter de me
confronter aux temps et vous raconter
quelque chose dans un temps conscrits je
pourrais vivre comme on le faisait avant
la révolution industrielle avec le
soleil dire je ne dors peu sadique avant
la révolution industrielle les gens ne
faisaient pas des nuits entières il se
réveille dans la nuit il passé deux
heures debout et puis se recoucher et
puis se disait voyons-nous tantôt
voyons-nous quand le soleil sera levé
voyons nous au coucher du soleil
en revanche il ya une leçon que j'ai pu
revenir éventuellement
ses epictète qui nous la donne
epictète ce philosophe de l'antiquité
nous dit
qu'on ne peut et qu'on ne doit agir
et qu'on ne doit désirer que ce que l'on
peut obtenir
et s'il ya une petite leçon de vie de
ces moments passés de ces deux
expériences de la mort plus ou moins
fantasmée plus ou moins proche c'est
bien celle-ci de ne désirer que ce que
l'on peut obtenir et c'est ainsi
peut-être que l'on retrouve un peu
malgré tout la vanité que cela peut
produire un peu de sens à notre
existence
merci
[Applaudissements]